Iron Man 2 versus fat Jesus battle to
the death or at least insanity due date
after 23 years and the death of John
Hughes we finally get the unofficial
sequel to planes trains and automobiles
so due date stars Robert Downey jr. a
really short-tempered father-to-be who's
trying to get back to LA in time for the
birth of his first child and fat Jesus
who is one of those get under your skin
with every syllable types but he's also
Robert Downey jr. is only hope of
getting back and the reason it's funny
because of dialogue based comedic timing
were watch's Robert Downey jr. would
pretty much be a Rolex so mix that with
Zach Galifianakis this character do I
really need to say more because we all
know someone like that we all know at
least one I know one I roomed with one
roomed with one another video for
another time honestly these two are
pretty much comedic gold I mean let's
take two masters of opposing comedic
craft and put them in a movie together I
mean you're already laughing before you
know what the script is even though I do
feel like there are a few scenes in this
movie that are borrowed straight from
planes trains and automobiles I mean not
just the premise but a few scenes at
least a couple scenes but of course in
this movie there's drug use and the
situation's are a lot more extreme but
it is the director of the hangover not
Ferris Bueller's Day Off but actually my
main fear in this movie was that they
showed all the funny scenes in the
trailers but not so they only showed 93%
but not a hundred but when they show the
entire joke unfold in the movie rather
than just the punchline that they show
in the trailer it is still funny there
were definitely scenes that I laughed
out loud in this movie we're talking not
just lol we're talking Huma fowl or Roth
loom foul yeah that one the movie has to
go cross-country in about an hour and a
half so it feels kind of rushed at times
like it seems like they're in one place
simply for one punchline then the next
scene they're in the next state kind of
gets annoying but what can I say
Galifianakis and Downey jr. they work
well together I laugh in the movie the
movie did its job so I would say I would
actually buy this movie even on blu-ray
if I didn't already have planes trains
and automobiles and that as they say is
that but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more than click
right here to see more
[Music]